yo guys this is prestige here with my
seventh I'm gonna call my seven my son
bit 7 episode of my divine our divine
survival and yeah for those of you that
knew this i play with the mod divine RPG
and we just do stuff it's a crazy mod
has tons of stuff you can see well I'm
the wrong game mode gym 0 0 you know why
wasn't neil gaiman you can see I have
all this other armor this stuff all is
also gone like our but yeah so I went
yes all last episode I went to the end I
returned from then I got some stuff
ready in the nether I went back to the
end killed some people picked up some
iron a few more diamonds yeah you see
more under stones and yeah so we are
going to get right into what i want to
do with the episode 2 day which is kill
a watcher now for that we're gonna need
to go in the nethers you can only small
in another and I made the eye of the
wall called I'll wash are using an eye
of the watcher 3 molten stones and a
hell stoning get I'm pretty sure that's
the recipe Oh exit okay and yeah you see
I made my mind up some sitting with my
Ruby chick ex I was actually questioning
I wasn't sure if the chick acts would
break uh obsidian since sometimes they
like I've heard like workers doesn't
break obsidian like for some reason I
don't know some of the pics don't but it
does and what's the XP over there hmm
all gasp OH somebody expedia think oh I
think I've got in here ok let's kills
cast there you go and I made setup seen
this took a long time to mine and I test
it i did test it out in creative like
this specific one and i should be
relatively safe like all I should take a
few some damage but not too much and yes
so watcher Wow
oh man so okay okay you know what yeah a
lot of the hits hit he'll hit a lot but
can we turn it down even more a he'll
hit a lot but a lot of them won't do me
any damage so I'm just gonna continue
smacking him in his little face yep and
we're gonna need some food so our health
of generates we're nice nice peaceful
lines yeah yeah come on okay maybe he's
our dope I thought he stopped attacking
for a sec even if I die can just come
back here and he should stay spawned
like he shouldn't be spawn so that
should be good he drops 100 nether
ingots a blue Firestone possibly a
statue and a certain amount of divine
charts hopefully I'll get to divine
stones i get to it and divine tones no I
want to hopefully I get to blue fire
stone since that means I want to kill
another one of them to create the portal
to our channel which is an awesome place
of full of stuff so he's almost dead and
waiver dance go there we go and we see
all the loot oh look at all them look at
all them levels he is a boss so makes
sense that it's what what has happened I
know yeah for you see that is a hundred
and what the oh what the heck of
scorcher okay hi I didn't invite you in
here I'll take your drops though and
drops yeah blazes it's like the high
think that's the first one of we've
encountered and there goes our door okay
then well now let's get out of another
since we don't want to spend any more
time in this dimension that we have to
since I don't really care for this
dimension and a where we go whoo I don't
get why I have that well yeah I have a
lot about ender pearls and I really like
using them is transport I also spent a
ton of time in the
dr I dimension and I gotta drive I chest
and it says it has infinite durability
but the durability bar is going down
should it doesn't even exist and I can i
enchanted it in here and I got some epic
enchantments so ones like we can learn
just back up so I have no idea what's
going on with that so oh dang it I'm
just be there for them blue Firestone
just throw you there and please not exit
completely sure what I can make with
those so we won't be making anything
those because I don't know why I came
back with those yeah a divine charge
next to the divine rock makes sense this
is just over with IVAC i made like you
chests I kind of forget all the changes
I made so if i don't go over them accept
my apologies yeah i got fortune to you
on this bad boy yeah i guess we can
enchant a book for level 30 and hope for
the best come on the best sharma that's
not bad that's bad we have like one or
two of those and yeah i don't know where
the chest is so I'm I have an idea where
it is so I'm gonna go there and the Pro
and because i have this full set of
elite real on my armor I take no fall
damage so it's like the ender pearls
perfect so i can i can tell them as much
as I want well that took a while what
what what oh I did I do it wrong right
yeah through the wrong way ok oh yeah
it's definitely much faster than stop it
much faster than walking
you can do to do dude boo I say it's
right evening yeah I kind of carries
over okay we might have passed it I've
actually never gone towards it uh using
and the pros like on away from the
portal um I've no idea where it is I'm
not doing my torches are here knew you
had a line of tortures going towards it
yet no clue when I threw that one that
got me off track must be up messed me up
quite so oh fail um any torches but
we're gonna go back just because I had
no idea oh hello that was close yes it's
a little to the other side of the lava
torch haha yes it is so where we got to
be got this don't worry I know where I'm
going I don't where I'm going and who
that should be good should get us in the
vicinity okay okay there it is rua good
and i'm just gonna I'm hoping the chest
is in this chest ah fun it's plenty hot
hmm
so drab aight chestplate know why wasn't
here ok seriously if I care if i can
really lost it i'm just gonna spawn
another one because Thank You triplets
very very nice today hmm that sucks is
this the top those make sense ok well
I'm not going to stay in here gosh I'm
gonna stay in here longer than I need to
but make it think we'll oh yeah I don't
know why hey that every single time so
strongly I bet here where the heck is it
really light all right I'm completely
baffled about where I put it oh why do I
put it in here but yeah full set of dr I
armor gives me a plus 3 Twilight or
drops and you see I got some epic and
gentlemen's on that it has durability I
don't into infinite uses whatever ok I'm
sorry that that that is can it confuse
me now also wait wait i was told that
this looks nasty and if this is look
nasty the entire time and I haven't
listened to you guys and I'm sorry but
we're going to replace that with wooden
wat phnom ok we're gonna place that with
wood wood all right so uh one of you
know and both put up boom boom and go
they look better anything does with a
stone button look at on it though and it
lets go this week 04 would ya to get it
we go oh well I don't care others when
your way into that is what the arbor
pressure plate to this pic is too
powerful so now a button here we go oh
um um bump there we go no not come on
there we go think it last longer too if
so that's awesome actually an interview
and their see I have all these torches
all churches what should we do want to
bow with an infinite also i have knocked
back and Louie on the sword if I think I
sure you guys in rock back maybe not the
looting but yeah I was hoping for to
blue fire on account of that looting mmm
what should we do oh I found some white
mushrooms I think I think I showed you
guys that before yeah I'mI'm just like
like like definitely last longer uh I've
no idea what I'm doing oh I thought I
had some apples um yeah
OOP just doing this don't mind me don't
mind me I'll keep them fly gold apples
with me the apples in there if I gold
nugget in there keep apples yeah so uh
should we go drive aight i probably
spend this enchanting first life 3 v's i
need more of those hmm let's just chat
in the book OOP oh dang it come on level
20 Chapman 20-something chairman I'll
take anything in 20 you know what no no
no actually I'll get like a high teen
I'll be okay with that oh dang i want oh
yeah rest brawl BS know what that can
only make bedrock armor since that
protects me from fire lava and blast I
mean you're testing them so we're going
here 1001 possibility yeah it doesn't
record any of my achievements ever so
yeah yeah I've spent a lot of time in
this dimension did
level 10 10 driver to drive revving a
drab right drive i magnin also one guy
just suggested to me a mod called um
better dungeons and I looked at it for
about two minutes like a video of it and
it looked really cool so i think i might
implement that into this game into them
i played through it would have to be in
New chunks but it would give me
something else to do in the overworld
since right now I really don't have much
since like I would there would be a
little more of a challenge like I would
probably still kill them and about a hit
like most creatures but it'd be better
than what we have now I'll go away Corey
go away go away I don't like you oh cool
fact I only I don't get hit killed by
one uh did I don't get one hit by cory's
or I don't want i'm wearing the other
armor hunk of why I'm wearing this in
the morning protects me from fall damage
yeah but one this this looks sexier II
I'm going to beat up well we're back in
now I'm gonna beat you ow yeah yeah be
gone with you thank you I just want you
to solve that's it just you sold yeah
God with you we killed a watcher that
was pretty awesome there we go let's
convert some souls those things are
swindle in the quarries and have loved
the fun when we get the advanced
quarries yeah more of you guys spawned
okay okay yeah let's all take three yeah
come on like it yeah I thought I thought
I didn't die one hit but I guess I do
oh whatever yeah like oh yeah we keep
the souls yeah for you people wondering
i have a mod that lets me keep my
inventory when i die because i want to
go and have to search for stuff yeah i'm
lazy what's up boop boop boop boop boop
boop oh we've just enough for a another
chunk wait can we make boots out of 42
today even get them yeah I did boots
come on something we can make boots yeah
boots she waited use each am than the
boots me like let's see can I can I
panties yeah what the heck these to be
infinite or whatever whatevs what does
bro give out that's for wat i have for
with my harlem light no i don't ok so a
drive aight you get it forget trip with
the Freak the driver is full by itself
what the heck man that'll make sense
yeah well I'm going to throw this key on
there the backup gear and like real my
helmet really meant how did you soon he
also have a lot of times it's like I
gotta get going soon well we showed you
a little more drive right a captain
boots we killed the watch I was a big
thing the cow pen there's only them that
when they breed like if we're gonna have
to breathe bread ones out here I feel
like I should like colonize the land
around me more like I can make a robe
stretch in like make building there do
something with that area I don't know
what to do what to do many possibilities
with this world even though the dungeons
would be a new described tangent even
the dungeons would be in a new new
blocks like I'd have to load new chunks
it's yeah as I was saying it's like
still someone to do sorrow and it the
things that you required minecraftforge
so it should work with a one of the best
idea to do that but it should be good to
work with this mod since this model i
use i'm using forge so yeah I think
that's going to be about it for the
episode yeah but somewhere i know from
night crab cual canyon sure and yeah so
i hope you all enjoyed if you do really
did enjoy the you like comment rate or
subscribe if you knew i really suggest
to subscribe since it's awesome and yeah
well voice crack in a yawn like it balls
all be seen you guys later hope you
enjoyed um share this video if you guys
really like this share it and like you
guys say i've got i got a lot of
comments it being like oh you should do
more yeah yeah we love it which i'm very
grateful for i think for anybody that's
ever said you like my videos it's it
means a lot it does but like if you guys
it go and share my videos and like I get
your friends to watch them so I gap then
all all then I'll see it in the views
and the likes and stuff all beep I'll
put out videos faster since I have a lot
of videos like it's not i'm not rushing
to put them out but yeah just do your
best to tell your friends and share it
around where you're going the facebooks
on the twitters I do have a Twitter so
follow mean that even though I haven't
said I mean I can post something in a
month Wow to fail but yeah okay peace
out guys